There is no doubt from public opinion polls that people care so much about the issue of sincerity
The person they deal with, whether that person is their doctor or their political leader.
However, it is more complicated. We often do not want to know the truth. Do you
Want to know that your husband is cheating on you? Do you want to know that person
Which you recommend to do something in your company scares? Would you like to know that
Are your children taking heroin? Of course these things are all things you want to know but you
Of course you do not want to know. So the question is whether we are already
We want to catch a very complicated liar. We think we want it. What if we discover that both presidential candidates
Do you lie? When will we do? I'm not saying they're lying, and I never comment
To any person in a position or running for office. Only when they leave office does it become
Allowed ... Clinton said: "I did not have sex with that woman" and then
He called it. The term "woman" was placed at a distance from himself. there are many reasons
Behind lies people and some of them deserve respect. I study the lies that the community cares about, which he cares about
Usually by exposing them. The most common reason why people lie is in order
Avoid punishment for breaking the law. Usually, some laws are broken by mistake.
They may cut off the gallery very quickly and expect a $ 2,000-carrying vase.
You did not mean to do that. "Did you sign that vessel?" You will not say
"Yes, I did it ...." "No, I do not know who threw that pot.
"You do not want to be punished, but there
Many times you make the decision to break the law,
I will cheat and lie. I will not admit that I was cheated. No
I want to reveal my order. Therefore, the decision to lie is taken at the same time as a decision
Cheating. When we know people, we do the workshops by teaching people how to do it
Lies, it will take us 32 hours ... Discover the very small expression is over
Things are useful. It is an expression that lasts about 25 parts per second. We have tested
More than 15,000 people in all areas of life and more than 99 percent of them did not see these terms,
However, after an hour of online training, they can learn to see these terms. But
This expression may tell you that a person hides only a sense. this is a lie--
They do not tell you what they really feel. But may not tell you they are perpetrators
the crime. This is a terrible example but I have to use it - they found my wife dead.
I will be the first suspect because, unfortunately, the first person who often kills his wife
He is the husband ... "But I love my wife, I did not kill her
Their time they insult me! Time passes and they are not looking for
The real person. "I may feel very angry with them and hide my anger
You have noticed my anger hidden, it does not mean that I killed my wife. It just means that I am
I hid my anger. Now, if the lie is about what Paul already feels, and
You have noticed a very small expression, then you have discovered something. Second, know that
The signals for your cultural community are the signals you will only know. This is the specific body language,
But you know it originally. You can not - if I ask you how many signals are used in
America today, you will give me about 12 signal, but it is actually 80. If I see you
Each of these 80 signals, you will know its meaning. And one amazing signal
Which had a huge result is the most common signal we use is shaking the head,
Yes and no. I just made it. These are already "yes" and "no". But it happens
Very quickly. I worked in a case of a fief who embezzled more than 100
Million dollars. He was very famous but appeared Bernie Madoff. He accused this embezzler
People in a number of banks that they are part of the deal, this means that these banks
Will have to pay for the embezzlement. When asked about a person who falsely accused them
"Did it help you steal money?" "Yes, of course
"I did." He shook his head with a nod to the word no, so it was smaller than my movement
One signal. There is one facial expression.